soir année michel fize merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors une
mobilisation un peu inédite des gilet
jaune si l'on peut dire ainsi parce que
ça se déroule dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire des gilet jaune qui ont battu
le pavé étaient plusieurs centaines
aujourd'hui vous soutenez toujours cette
mobilisation
j'écoute et j'essaie toujours de la
comprendre
le premier enseignement que l'on peut
tirer c'est que ce mouvement
contrairement à ce qui est affirmé ici
ou là n'est pas mort que un problème
futile aussi grave que celui que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec le
coronavirus évidemment ne gomme pas d'un
coup de baguette magique les problèmes
sociaux je crois qu'il faut avoir
conscience qu'il ya aujourd'hui des gens
qui sont à la fois menacé par cette
épidémie mais qui sont aussi confiné
dans la misère au quotidien
on a vu que ça s'est pas très bien passé
quand même aujourd'hui a eu des tensions
en fin de matinée au départ du cortège
du côté de montparnasse avec un
dispositif de sécurité très serré parce
que les manifestants ont été menacés le
regard que vous portez sur le déroulé de
cette journée qui n'est pas encore
terminée puisqu'on en est à la
dispersion
il est vrai que on pouvait on pouvait
penser que peut-être le nombre de
participants serait très très faible
mais quand l'urgence est grande
évidemment il y a toutes les raisons de
continuer de continuer le combat
1 je rappelle encore une fois que le
pouvoir d'achat demeure sinistré que les
conditions d'accès un certain nombre de
services le logement les transports
demeure demeure délicat c'est
malheureusement toute la difficulté pour
un gouvernement qu'il doit traiter tous
les problèmes en même temps et pas
simplement traité traiter les urgences
qu'il y aujourd'hui une priorité de
santé publique
de santé individuel ne gomme pas encore
une fois le fait qu'il ya aussi un
énorme problème de santé social car la
société est en mauvaise santé pour un
nombre toujours important de gens et ils
le disent
samedi après samedi depuis maintenant
plus d'un an et demi la polémique on s'y
attend au lendemain de ce samedi de
mobilisation 70e actes parce qu'on a
entendu certains gilet jaune dont david
poulain pour le rappeler sur notre
antenne à dire que c'était pas vraiment
responsable de battre le pavé
aujourd'hui d'autres gilet jaune
comme david libeskind maintiennent qu'il
faut aller manifester
que faut-il en penser selon vous il y à
là il ya des divisions au sein même du
mouvement
maintenant vous savez bon il ya d'abord
ce constat qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il
n'ya pas malheureusement de risque de
risque zéro savez quand vous interdisez
le stade aux supporters pour le match
paris saint germain dortmund mais que
vous avez à l'extérieur 3000 personnes
qui sont pour le coup
confiné proches les unes des autres
quand vous avez encore les transports
publics qui fonctionne et on comprend la
raison pour laquelle ils puissent encore
fonctionner mais vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri
encore une fois d'une contamination vous
ouvrez votre courrier vous pouvez être
contaminé vous achetez vos fruits et
légumes qui ont pu être manipulé sans
gants d'ailleurs je m'étonne que parmi
les gestes de protection
on n'est pas recommandée ce qui me
paraît très quand même même peut-être la
première des mesures de portée des gants
de porter des gants un des gants souple
qui éviterait encore une fois des gestes
qui peuvent contaminer et les produits
et les personnes sur la suite du
mouvement certains annoncent déjà un
acte 71 72
comment est ce que vous vous pensez que
les choses vont évoluer pour alléger les
jours une prochainement dans ce contexte
on le rappelle un de crise sanitaire
vous savez je reprendrai peut-être le
slogan qui est affichée sur les
banderoles on ne lâchera rien je pense
encore une fois qu' il ya une telle
détresse pour beaucoup de français
qu'aujourd'hui le combat paraît
incontournable
il faut il faut continuer je crois que
les robes noires
on les reverra les blouses blanches
également qui sont en plus confrontés à
un problème supplémentaire celui d'une
épidémie d'une épidémie à grande échelle
donc tout laisse penser que quand les
problèmes sociaux n'auront pas été
réglés les uns après les autres
et bien il y aura toujours des personnes
pour lever les drapeaux soulever les
slogans le samedi donc oui il y aura un
71ème un acte probablement 1 72e
et peut-être que nous nous reparlerons
pour le centième actes et l'appel à la
solidarité nationale dans le contexte
actuel un des crises d coronavirus
écouter ça ce sont des choix politiques
un bon qu'il y ait un moment de
communion nationale
vu l'importance encore une fois de ceux
de ce fléau on peut on peut comprendre
mais je crois qu on ne comprendrait pas
non plus que subitement la question du
fonctionnement de nos institutions
la question de savoir si le régime de
retraite est un bon régime ou pas un bon
régime
toutes ces questions restent sur la
table donc elle réapparaîtront de toute
façon
et notamment par le biais médiatique le
moment venu je pense que pour le moment
il faut considérer que une société c'est
à la fois la santé des individus et la
santé d'une communauté c'est l'ensemble
merci beaucoup michel fize je rappelle
que vous êtes la sociologue version du
livre à une insurrection populaire au
destin encore incertain aux éditions
amazon merci à vous